This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. It's a story that is familiar to every American. A young George Washington chops down his father's prized cherry tree. When his father confronts him about the deed, young George doesn't hide. He doesn't deflect. He doesn't minimize. I cannot tell a lie, he says.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这是一个每个美国人都耳熟能详的故事。年幼的乔治·华盛顿砍倒了他父亲珍视的樱桃树。当父亲就此事质问他时，小乔治没有躲藏。他没有推诿。他没有轻描淡写。他说，我不能撒谎。
I did cut it. Instead of scolding him, George's father embraces him. He declares that. his son's honesty is worth more than a thousand trees. This tale, first popularized in the early 19th century, is one of America's most cherished moral parables. It's Washington's birthday and the truthful he of the cherry tree would look down on me and frown. It celebrates honesty and the courage that often accompanies it.
我确实砍了它。乔治的父亲非但没有责骂他，反而拥抱了他。他宣称，儿子的诚实比一千棵树还要珍贵。这个故事在19世纪初首次流行，是美国最受推崇的道德寓言之一。今天是华盛顿的生日，如果那位樱桃树下的诚实男孩俯视着我，他可能会皱起眉头。它赞美诚实以及随之而来的勇气。
Yet the story is enduring power rests on a deep irony. The parable is almost certainly a fabrication, a lie invented to teach the importance of telling the truth. The myth makers behind the story believe that fiction could serve a higher truth, that people might be inspired to be truthful by the story of a hero who could not tell a lie. The story of George Washington and the cherry tree reminds us
然而，这个故事持久的力量源于一种深刻的讽刺。这个寓言几乎可以肯定是虚构的，是一个为了教导人们诚实的重要性而编造的谎言。故事背后的神话制造者相信，虚构可以服务于更高的真理，人们可能会被一个不能撒谎的英雄的故事所激励，从而变得诚实。乔治·华盛顿和樱桃树的故事提醒我们，
that the motivations behind honesty and deception are rarely straightforward. Lies can sometimes uphold more. moral ideals and truths can sometimes be wielded to wound. Today on the show, and in a companion episode on Hidden Brain Plus, can engaging in deception ever be the right thing to do? The Psychology of Good Lies This week on Hidden Brain. We grew up learning that honesty is a virtue, that good people tell the truth, and that
诚实和欺骗背后的动机很少是直截了当的。谎言有时可以维护更高的道德理想，而真理有时会被用来伤害他人。今天在节目中，以及在《隐藏的大脑 Plus》的配套剧集中，我们探讨：进行欺骗有时是正确的做法吗？“善意谎言的心理学”，本周在《隐藏的大脑》中播出。我们从小就被教导诚实是一种美德，好人会说真话，而
liars are bad people. But life has a way of complicating simple lessons. A husband hides his elderly wife's dementia diagnosis in order to spare her needless worry. A friend says, you look great, knowing it isn't true. A parent tells her child that everything will be okay when it might not be. These moments leave us wondering,
撒谎者是坏人。但生活总有办法让简单的教训变得复杂。一位丈夫隐瞒了年迈妻子患有痴呆症的诊断结果，是为了让她免受不必要的担忧。一位朋友明明知道不是真的，却说“你看起来棒极了”。一位母亲告诉孩子一切都会好起来的，尽管事实可能并非如此。这些时刻让我们不禁思考，
when is telling the truth cruel and when do lies become an act of love? At the University of Chicago, Emma Levine studies the psychology of truth-telling and deception. Emma Levine, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you so much for having me. It's great to be here. Emma, a few years ago, you were planning your wedding and you faced a dilemma regarding the guest list. I understand it involved your grandfather and his friends. Yes. My wonderful grandfather,
什么时候说真话是残忍的，什么时候谎言变成了爱的表现？在芝加哥大学，艾玛·莱文研究说真话和欺骗的心理学。艾玛·莱文，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。非常感谢邀请我。很高兴来到这里。艾玛，几年前，你在筹备婚礼时，在宾客名单上遇到了一个两难境地。我听说这涉及到你的祖父和他的朋友们。是的。我那非常、非常爱我的好祖父，
who loves me very, very much, wanted to celebrate my big day with all of his friends. The only problem was we had run out of invitations and space at our venue. I'm imagining this must have caused some stress for the bride to be. Yeah, I was pretty stressed. Not only because I was planning the wedding and had to deal with, right, this tension between, you know, hurting his feelings and telling him his friends couldn't come or telling the truth. But I was also studying for my qualifying exams. This is my first year of graduate school. Wow.
想和他的所有朋友一起庆祝我的大喜之日。唯一的问题是我们已经没有请柬了，场地也没有空间了。我能想象这对准新娘来说一定造成了一些压力。是的，我压力很大。不仅因为我在筹备婚礼，必须处理这种紧张关系——你知道的，既要避免伤害他的感情并告诉他朋友们不能来，又要说实话。而且我当时还在准备资格考试。这是我读研究生的第一年。哇。
How did you address this dilemma, Emma? What did you do? Well, my mother was actually an integral part of all this. She was helping me plan my hometown wedding in Milwaukee, Wisconsin, whereas she lived and still lives. And she basically took over. She said, you know what? I'm going to take care of this.
你是怎么解决这个两难境地的，艾玛？你做了什么？嗯，我母亲实际上是这一切中不可或缺的一部分。她当时在帮我筹备我在威斯康星州密尔沃基家乡的婚礼，她当时住在那里，现在也住在那里。她基本上接手了这件事。她说，你知道吗？我会处理这件事的。
I won't let my dad, who was my grandfather, bring his friends to the wedding. I don't want you to sweat it. I want you to worry at all. Great. Yeah, it was great. I was very relieved. I was very grateful.
我不会让我爸爸——也就是我的祖父——带他的朋友来参加婚礼。我不想让你为此操心。我不想让你有任何担忧。太棒了。是的，这太棒了。我感到非常宽慰。我非常感激。
The wedding was amazing. Best day of my life. Nothing was problematic at all. But a few days after the wedding, I started receiving a few gifts from people I never heard of. And I did some digging, right. So I get these strange gifts, looking up the names online,
婚礼非常棒。是我一生中最美好的一天。没有任何问题。但在婚礼几天后，我开始收到一些我从未听说过的人送来的礼物。我做了一些调查，对吧。所以我收到了这些奇怪的礼物，在网上查找名字，
and the return addresses. And I realized, oh, hmm, they're coming from. this place near where my grandfather lives. And I asked my mom, who is this? What's happening? And it turns out, these people were invited to my wedding. Wow. My mother photocopied my wedding invitations to send to them. Wow. Yeah. And I think what's funny is it all kind of worked out quite perfectly. So your mom actually lied to you. She told you that
还有回信地址。我意识到，哦，嗯，它们来自我祖父住处附近。我问我妈妈，这是谁？发生了什么事？结果发现，这些人被邀请参加了我的婚礼。哇。我母亲复印了我的结婚请柬寄给了他们。哇。是的。而且我觉得有趣的是，这一切最终都非常完美地解决了。所以你妈妈实际上对你撒了谎。她告诉你
that your grandfather's friends were not going to be invited when she herself actually invited them? Exactly. Yes. What if these friends had shown up at the wedding, Emma, you would have been horrified? Yeah, I would have been horrified. It would have been awful. But they didn't. And she said at the time, once I discovered her lie, that she knew. She knew in her heart that they were not going to come. They were elderly and from out of state, there was no way they were going to travel to this wedding. And so she took a bet and she took care of it and she lied to me along the way. How did you feel about the lie?
你祖父的朋友不会被邀请，而她自己实际上邀请了他们？完全正确。是的。如果这些朋友出现在婚礼上，艾玛，你会感到惊恐吗？是的，我会感到惊恐。那会很糟糕。但他们没有来。她在当时说，当我发现她的谎言后，她说她知道。她心里知道他们不会来。他们年纪大了，又住在外州，他们根本不可能来参加这场婚礼。所以她赌了一把，她处理了这件事，而且在这个过程中对我撒了谎。你对这个谎言感觉如何？
I was impressed by it. I mean, it's not only a good story, but, and I could imagine it would have turned out very differently, right? As you said, if they had showed up. But they didn't. And because they didn't, it just seemed like, wow, that was bold, but also the right decision. I wasn't troubled. I studied for my qualifying exams. I didn't give it a second thought. Ended up doing great. My wedding was perfect. And no one was worse for the wear. I want to play you a clip from a TV show that presents a similar situation. It features the
我对此印象深刻。我的意思是，这不仅是一个好故事，而且，我可以想象如果他们真的出现了，结果会大不相同，对吧？正如你所说。但他们没有来。因为他们没来，这看起来就像是，哇，这很大胆，但也是正确的决定。我没有感到困扰。我准备了我的资格考试。我没再多想。结果做得很好。我的婚礼很完美。而且没有人受到伤害。我想给你播放一段电视节目的片段，它呈现了一个类似的情况。它以
characters Jerry and Elaine from the sitcom Seinfeld. And this is just after they have visited friends who've had a baby. Is it me or was that the ugliest best? Baby, you have ever seen. Oh, I couldn't look. It was like a Pekinese. Boy, it was too much chlorine in that gene pool. And you know, the thing is, they'll never know. No one's ever going to tell them.
情景喜剧《宋飞正传》中的角色杰瑞和伊莱恩为特色。这就在他们拜访了刚生了孩子的朋友之后。是我多心了，还是那是你见过的最丑的婴儿？哦，我都不敢看。它就像一只北京犬。天哪，那基因库里的氯气太多了。而且你知道吗，关键是，他们永远不会知道。没有人会告诉他们。
Oh, you have to lie. Oh, it's a must-lie situation. Yes, it's a must-lie situation. A must-lie situation. Jerry is saying there is no option but to lie. Now, I suppose there is an option, but Emma, can you imagine visiting friends and telling them that their baby looks ghastly? No, I don't think you can do that.
哦，你必须撒谎。哦，这是一种必须撒谎的情况。是的，这是一种必须撒谎的情况。一种必须撒谎的情况。杰瑞说除了撒谎别无选择。现在，我想确实有一个选择，但艾玛，你能想象拜访朋友并告诉他们他们的孩子看起来很可怕吗？不，我不认为你能那样做。
I think Jerry's right. As one of my favorite psychologists, I'd agree, that this is a must-lie situation. You argue that besides good lies, there could also be bad truths. What are bad truths, Emma? Bad truths are truths that cause unnecessary harm. So they might cause emotional pain and suffering. and not lead to learning and growth and understanding. And so this seems like a bad truth, right?
我认为杰瑞是对的。作为我最喜欢的心理学家之一，我会同意，这是一种必须撒谎的情况。你认为除了善意的谎言，也可能存在恶意的真话。什么是恶意的真话，艾玛？恶意的真话是那些造成不必要伤害的真话。所以它们可能会导致情感上的痛苦和折磨，而不会带来学习、成长和理解。所以这看起来就是一种恶意的真话，对吧？
Knowing your baby is offensively ugly. He's hurtful, and there's really not much you can do about it. You're not going to get a facelift on an infant, right? So this is unnecessary harm. What do I need to know what you think about my baby that I think is beautiful, that I'm not going to change? So we've been talking about social situations where we need to shade the truth, but this might also be true of large-scale political and international situations.
知道你的孩子长得丑得令人反感。这很伤人，而且你真的对此无能为力。你不会给婴儿做整容手术，对吧？所以这是不必要的伤害。我为什么要了解你对我认为很漂亮、而且我也不会改变的孩子有什么看法呢？所以我们一直在谈论我们需要掩盖真相的社交场合，但这可能也适用于大规模的政治和国际局势。
In October 1962, the United States discovered that the Soviet Union was building nuclear military installations in Cuba, just 90 miles from Florida. Once completed, Soviet warheads could hit the continental United States within minutes. The John F. Kennedy administration faced a choice. They could tell the American public what was going on, Or they could lie. What did they do, Emma? They certainly didn't tell the public everything. For about a week after this discovery, the White House kept the information secret.
1962年10月，美国发现苏联正在古巴建造核军事设施，距离佛罗里达仅90英里。一旦建成，苏联的弹头可以在几分钟内击中美国大陆。约翰·F·肯尼迪政府面临一个选择。他们可以告诉美国公众正在发生什么，或者他们可以撒谎。他们做了什么，艾玛？他们当然没有告诉公众一切。在发现这一情况后的大约一周里，白宫对这些信息保密。
And Kennedy, meanwhile, assembled a group of top advisors to deliberate about this and what to do in private. And so then they secretly also backchanneled with the Soviet Union through trusted intermediaries. And then eventually announced to the nation that there would be this U.S. response of a quarantine. I'm imagining that if they had come clean on day one before they even knew what was going on before they had a plan, it could have triggered mass panic. Right. And that was part of the tradeoff, right? Do we inform the public fully and risk a panic and a premature military response and escalation? Or do we engage in some form of deception for at least some time? Now, is this also a case in which deception had both costs and benefits? So the lies that, that were told by the Kennedy administration
与此同时，肯尼迪召集了一群高级顾问在私下里商讨此事以及应对措施。然后他们还通过可信的中间人与苏联进行了秘密的幕后沟通。最终向全国宣布，美国将采取一种“隔离”的应对措施。我能想象，如果他们在第一天，在甚至不知道发生了什么、没有计划之前就全盘托出，可能会引发大规模恐慌。没错。这就是权衡的一部分，对吧？我们是完全告知公众，冒着引发恐慌、过早采取军事反应和局势升级的风险？还是至少在一段时间内进行某种形式的欺骗？现在，这也是一个欺骗既有成本又有收益的案例吗？所以肯尼迪政府所说的谎言
might have helped avert panic. It might have even helped avert a potential war between nuclear powers, but it might have also contributed to the long-term and very consequential undermining of the American public's trust in what their leaders were telling them. Absolutely.
可能有助于避免恐慌。它甚至可能有助于避免核大国之间潜在的战争，但它也可能导致了美国公众对领导人所言的信任在长期内受到非常严重的损害。绝对是这样。
And I think this is the tension that comes with lying. We could argue that this was the right lie to tell that it successfully promoted the U.S. interests and avoided a lot of harm. but it's never without some long-term cost. And in this case, the cost is trust, trust in what your leaders are telling you. We've been told that we should always tell the truth,
我认为这就是撒谎带来的紧张关系。我们可以争辩说，这是正确的谎言，它成功地促进了美国的利益并避免了许多伤害。但它永远不会没有长期的代价。在这种情况下，代价就是信任，对领导人所言的信任。我们一直被告知我们应该永远说真话，
and we tell others, like our employees and our students and our kids, that they ought to do the same. But do we really live by this rule? Should we? When we come back, the unwritten rules that govern when it's okay to lie. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedant.
我们也告诉其他人，比如我们的员工、学生和孩子，他们也应该这样做。但我们真的遵守这条规则吗？我们应该遵守吗？回来后，我们将探讨那些规定何时可以撒谎的潜规则。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。
Psychological research finds that people lie in about 20% of their social interactions. We may say that honesty is the best policy, but it's not a policy that many of us follow to the letter. Instead, we obey an unspoken code, a set of rules about when lying is acceptable. Psychologist Emma Levine has studied those unwritten rules. She says there is a a hidden logic behind our deceptions. Emma, the idea that we should always tell the truth is a bedrock principle of many fates and cultures. What are some of the traditions in which this command is emphasized?
心理学研究发现，人们在约20%的社交互动中会撒谎。我们可能会说诚实是上策，但这并不是我们许多人严格遵循的政策。相反，我们遵守一种不成文的准则，一套关于何时撒谎是可以接受的规则。心理学家艾玛·莱文研究了这些不成文的规则。她说，我们的欺骗行为背后有一种隐藏的逻辑。艾玛，我们应该永远说真话的观点是许多信仰和文化的基石原则。有哪些传统强调了这一准则？
Well, I think it's emphasized everywhere. Children growing up with religion often learn about the Ten Commandments that emphasize rules about avoiding deception. Parents, right, tell this to their children. corporate codes of conduct frequently emphasize integrity and honesty. So we see this everywhere, particularly in the U.S., where we think a lot about the freedom of speech, which in part promotes honesty, that we should always be engaging in truthful discourse and speech. You say that this presents us with something of a puzzle, which is, even as we lie, even as Jerry Seinfeld says,
嗯，我认为它在任何地方都受到强调。从小接触宗教的孩子通常会学习关于避免欺骗的“十诫”。父母，对吧，会告诉他们的孩子。企业行为准则经常强调诚信和诚实。所以我们在任何地方都能看到这一点，特别是在美国，我们非常看重言论自由，这在一定程度上促进了诚实，即我们应该始终进行真实的交流和言论。你说这给我们带来了一个难题，那就是，即使我们撒谎，即使像杰瑞·宋飞所说的那样，
there are must-lie situations. We instruct our kids, our colleagues, and our students to always tell the truth. That's a paradox. It is a paradox, and it's very confusing. And this is kind of the nuance that we have to figure out every day of our lives from a very young age. You tell your children, never lie. And then they hear you telling their sibling to tell their grandmother they love this gift that they hate. And we're just puzzling and fumbling our way through.
存在必须撒谎的情况。我们还是教导我们的孩子、同事和学生要永远说真话。这是一个悖论。这确实是一个悖论，而且非常令人困惑。这就是我们从很小的时候起，在生活中每天都必须弄清楚的细微差别。你告诉你的孩子，永远不要撒谎。然后他们听到你告诉他们的兄弟姐妹去告诉祖母他们喜欢这个他们讨厌的礼物。我们只是在困惑和摸索中前行。
When in reality, they're very clear situations underlying the exceptions. We just don't say them out loud that much. So your research has identified these situations in which people generally agree that it's morally acceptable to lie. You've identified a number of these situations in which dishonesty is seen as acceptable and perhaps even preferable to honesty. One of these is when the target of the lie is incapacitated in some way. So in one study, you presented volunteers with a scenario in which an employee has just turned in a report to a manager, even as the employee struggles with a difficult personal situation. We've run a lot of these studies in which we're trying to manipulate and think about what changes our fundamental judgment of lying. And so in this particular situation, we're trying to play with the fragility of the target.
而实际上，例外情况背后的逻辑非常清晰。我们只是没有大声说出来而已。所以你的研究确定了人们普遍认为撒谎在道德上是可以接受的情况。你确定了许多在这种情况下不诚实被视为可以接受，甚至可能比诚实更可取的场景。其中之一是当谎言的对象处于某种无能为力的状态时。因此，在一项研究中，你向志愿者展示了一个场景，其中一名员工刚刚向经理提交了一份报告，尽管该员工正处于困难的个人境况中。我们进行了很多这样的研究，试图操纵并思考是什么改变了我们对撒谎的基本判断。所以在这个特定的情况下，我们试图利用对象的脆弱性。
So as you stated, right, the employee has turned in a report. The manager doesn't think it has been done well. If you just ask, right, should the manager tell the employee the truth? Most people say yes, right? Ninety-seven percent of participants say, yes, the right, 97 percent of participants say, yes, the right, 97 percent say you should lie. But if you ask the separate sample of participants, what they should do in a very similar situation in which the employee's father was, just hospitalized, now suddenly a lot more people think you should lie. So almost 20% of participants think you should lie and only 80% say you should tell the truth. And we find the same results when you actually ask people what they would want to be told as the employee. People want to be lied to in this moment of fragility. And so that's doing a lot of work here. The state of being vulnerable includes people who might be distracted from an important goal if they were told the truth. One student described a scenario that played out in her own life involving a friend who was about to take a difficult exam. What happened and how did this young woman handle the situation?
正如你所说，对吧，员工提交了一份报告。经理认为做得不好。如果你只是问，对吧，经理应该告诉员工真相吗？大多数人说会，对吧？97%的参与者说，会，97%的参与者说，会，97%的人说你应该撒谎。但如果你问另一组参与者，在员工的父亲刚刚住院的非常相似的情况下他们应该怎么做，现在突然间更多的人认为你应该撒谎。所以几乎20%的参与者认为你应该撒谎，只有80%的人说你应该说真话。当我们询问人们作为员工时他们希望被告知什么时，我们发现了同样的结果。人们希望在这个脆弱的时刻被欺骗。所以这在其中起到了很大的作用。处于脆弱状态的人包括那些如果被告知真相可能会从重要目标中分心的人。一位学生描述了她自己生活中发生的一个场景，涉及一个即将参加困难考试的朋友。发生了什么，这位年轻女性是如何处理这种情况的？
Yeah, people think about fragility and distraction as kind of these temporary states that merit deception. So in this one particular instance, a participant writes about this time that she withheld the truth from her friend, the truth being that a boy wasn't interested in her. And she didn't tell her friend because the friend was studying for an exam. She didn't want to throw her off her study patterns and risk undermining her exam performance. So she withheld the truth and told her later. And that's not all that different from what my mother did when I was studying for my qualifying exams.
是的，人们认为脆弱和分心是那种值得欺骗的临时状态。所以在这个特定的例子中，一位参与者写到了她向朋友隐瞒真相的那次经历，真相是那个男孩对她不感兴趣。她没有告诉她的朋友，因为朋友正在准备考试。她不想打乱她的学习节奏，冒着破坏她考试表现的风险。所以她隐瞒了真相，后来才告诉她。这和我准备资格考试时我母亲所做的事情没什么不同。
She waited. another situation in which people seem to think it's okay to lie is if the target of the lie is unable to understand the truth. So in other words, should you tell someone who is in very frail health about a death in the family? You presented volunteers with the story of a man named Jeff. What was the story, Emma? Participants imagine being the caregiver for an elderly man named Jeff, and they learn that Jeff's estranged daughter has passed away. So that's the setup that everybody learns.
她等待着。人们认为可以撒谎的另一种情况是，如果谎言的对象无法理解真相。换句话说，你应该告诉一个身体非常虚弱的人家里有人去世了吗？你向志愿者展示了一个名叫杰夫的男人的故事。故事是什么，艾玛？参与者想象自己是一个名叫杰夫的老人的护理人员，他们得知杰夫疏远的女儿去世了。这就是每个人都知道的设定。
And then we randomly assign participants to a condition in which Jeff is either not cognitively compromised or is cognitively compromised. So in the control condition, you know that Jeff is in good physical and mental health despite being quite elderly. And in that situation, almost everyone believes that you should tell the truth. Only about 7% of participants 7.7% believe it is ethical to lie to Jeff about the death of his daughter. But in another condition, we tell participants that although Jeff is in good physical health, he suffers from severe dementia, right? Implying that he cannot necessarily make sense of reality and he's easily confused. And now, almost a third of participants believe the right thing to do is to lie. So this isn't because Jeff is in compromised physical health.
然后我们随机将参与者分配到杰夫要么认知没有受损，要么认知受损的条件中。在对照组中，你知道杰夫尽管年纪很大，但身体和精神状况良好。在这种情况下，几乎每个人都认为你应该说真话。只有约7%的参与者，7.7%的人认为对杰夫隐瞒他女儿去世的消息是合乎道德的。但在另一种情况下，我们告诉参与者，尽管杰夫身体健康，但他患有严重的痴呆症，对吧？暗示他未必能理解现实，而且很容易感到困惑。现在，几乎三分之一的参与者认为正确的做法是撒谎。所以这不是因为杰夫身体状况不佳。
It's his mental health. It's his cognitive state, right? the degree to which we think he can understand and cope with this difficult truth. I actually have a friend who's going through a very similar situation. Her dad is suffering from dementia, and her mother, her dad's wife, passed away some time ago. And she's hesitated to tell her dad, who is in a nursing facility about the death of his wife. And I think part of her concern is also, if I told my dad what was happening, he would be very upset, but it's possible that he might actually forget about what happened by the next time I
是他的心理健康，是他的认知状态，对吧？我们认为他能理解和应对这个困难真相的程度。我实际上有一个朋友正在经历非常相似的情况。她的父亲患有痴呆症，而她的母亲，也就是她父亲的妻子，前段时间去世了。她一直犹豫是否要告诉住在疗养院的父亲他妻子去世的消息。我想她担心的部分原因也是，如果我告诉父亲发生了什么，他会非常难过，但有可能他下次再来时可能真的会忘记发生了什么。
come back. And then if I tell him again, he's going to suffer the grief over and over and over again. Right. And that's a terribly difficult situation. It's not that this is easy to handle and it's obvious, but there is a logic to it, right? A lot of people and health care ethicists have written about this. A lot of people would say, why should we cause this emotional pain to someone who can't truly cope and grieve with it? There's no necessary value in the information. So the social work researchers Diane Beach and Betty Kramer call this therapeutic fibbing. What is therapeutic fibbing, Emma? Therapeutic fibbing is, I think, a different name for prosocial lying, right? In this type of
然后如果我再告诉他一次，他就会一次又一次地承受悲伤。没错。那是一个极其困难的情况。这并不是说这很容易处理，而且显而易见，但它确实有逻辑，对吧？许多人和医疗保健伦理学家都写过关于这个问题的文章。许多人会说，为什么要给一个无法真正应对和悲伤的人造成这种情感痛苦呢？这些信息没有必然的价值。所以社会工作研究人员黛安·比奇和贝蒂·克莱默称之为“治疗性谎言”。什么是治疗性谎言，艾玛？我认为治疗性谎言是亲社会谎言的另一个名字，对吧？在这种类型的
situation in the health care setting, right? It's providing false statements and creating false beliefs with the purpose of therapy, emotional therapy, reducing distress, agitation, or suffering. And it's commonly used in dementia care. Another occasion in which community standards call on us to lie is when the target of the deception is near the end of his or her own life. You've presented volunteers with different versions of a vignette involving a cheating spouse. What are these vignettes? So imagine that your spouse or partner is very, very ill and in the hospital. And you've cheated on them in the past. So this is the situation we present to participants.
医疗保健环境下的情况，对吧？它是为了治疗的目的，即情感治疗、减少痛苦、焦虑或折磨，而提供虚假陈述并制造虚假信念。它常用于痴呆症护理。社区标准要求我们撒谎的另一个场合是当欺骗的对象接近他或她生命的尽头时。你向志愿者展示了涉及出轨配偶的不同版本的短片。这些短片是什么？所以想象你的配偶或伴侣病得非常、非常重，正在住院。而你过去曾欺骗过他们。所以这就是我们呈现给参与者的情况。
Should you tell them that you cheated on them? This is kind of the basic question, but we randomized some details of this vignette. In one situation, you know that your partner is very likely to recover. So in this case, about 30% of participants think it's the right thing to do to lie. So actually a substantial amount, even if your partner is likely to recover, think it's acceptable to lie to them about cheating. But this number goes up. It almost doubles when you know your partner is about to pass away. If your partner's about to pass away, in our particular vignette, we say they're likely to die within the next 24 hours. Now, About 64% of participants believe the right thing to do is to lie.
你应该告诉他们你欺骗了他们吗？这算是基本问题，但我们随机化了这个短片的一些细节。在一种情况下，你知道你的伴侣很有可能康复。在这种情况下，约30%的参与者认为撒谎是正确的做法。所以实际上有相当多的人，即使你的伴侣很可能康复，也认为对他们隐瞒出轨是可以接受的。但这个数字上升了。当你得知你的伴侣即将去世时，它几乎翻了一番。如果你的伴侣即将去世，在我们特定的短片中，我们说他们很可能在未来24小时内死亡。现在，约64%的参与者认为正确的做法是撒谎。
And again, what's the value of this information? Maybe it unburdens you as the communicator. You want to get it off your chest at the last moment that you have with this person. But for them, this is just something that causes emotional harm. And there's no relationship in which they can learn from this anymore. In some ways, these scenarios remind me of the 2019 movie The Farewell. It was inspired by the real-life experience of filmmaker Lulu Wang. After her grandmother was diagnosed with stage four lung cancer and given three months to live,
同样，这些信息的价值是什么？也许它减轻了你作为沟通者的负担。你想在与这个人共处的最后时刻把它说出来。但对他们来说，这只会造成情感伤害。而且他们已经没有关系可以从中学习了。在某些方面，这些场景让我想起了2019年的电影《别告诉她》。它的灵感来自电影制作人王子逸的真实经历。在她的祖母被诊断出患有肺癌晚期并被告知只剩下三个月生命后，
the family wanted to say goodbye without letting her know that she was dying. They felt that that would needlessly distress her. The filmmaker first told the story on the public radio show This American Life. I want to play you a clip from that story in which Lulu was talking with her father about what the family decided to do. My dad had an idea. So I said, all right, your uncle, maybe we can just, you know, stage your son's wedding early, one year early. Are you proud that you came up with this idea?
家人想在不让她知道自己快要去世的情况下告别。他们觉得那样会让她不必要地感到痛苦。这位电影制作人首先在公共广播节目《美国生活》中讲述了这个故事。我想播放一段那个故事的片段，其中王子逸正在和她的父亲谈论家人决定做什么。我爸爸有个主意。所以我说，好吧，叔叔，也许我们可以，你知道，提前举办你儿子的婚礼，提前一年。你为你想到这个主意感到自豪吗？
Well, you know, I'm the old, I'm the, everybody considered me is the smartest, you know, in the family. So, I mean, there's true. I mean. This was our plan. a giant goodbye party disguised as a giant wedding banquet. This is the lie that everybody agreed to lie. What do you hear in that story, Emma? I think it really highlights the complexity of truth-telling at the end of life,
嗯，你知道，我是那个，我是那个，每个人都认为我是家里最聪明的，你知道。所以，我的意思是，这是真的。我的意思是。这是我们的计划。一场伪装成盛大婚礼宴会的盛大告别派对。这就是每个人都同意撒的谎。你在那个故事里听到了什么，艾玛？我认为它确实突显了生命尽头说真话的复杂性，
but it also highlights the enormous cross-cultural variation we have in beliefs about truth-telling. So this, you know, the story, the farewell takes place in China. and particularly within the medical domain, there's a lot more emphasis in China than in the U.S. on hope and protection. And so it will feel maybe like an obligation among family members to protect their elders from negativity and despair,
但它也突显了我们在关于说真话的信念方面存在的巨大跨文化差异。所以这个，你知道，故事，《别告诉她》发生在在中国。特别是在医疗领域，中国比美国更强调希望和保护。因此，保护长辈免受消极情绪和绝望的影响，可能会被视为家庭成员之间的一种义务，
which comes from a cancer diagnosis. And that's, you know, something you hear that Wong's father is proud of, proud of honoring that value. And in the U.S., we don't really hear that. In the U.S., there's much greater moral emphasis on autonomy, the duty to inform others above the duty to provide hope. And so I think you just see this come out in different ways where we have different moral attitudes towards honesty, particularly at this end-of-life situation. I can imagine in an individualistic country like the United States, people might say, you know, if someone has three months left to live, you absolutely should tell them because that allows them to get their affairs in order.
这种消极情绪来自于癌症诊断。而且，你知道，那是你听到王子逸的父亲感到自豪的事情，为履行那种价值观感到自豪。而在美国，我们并没有真正听到那种声音。在美国，对自主权、告知他人的义务高于提供希望的义务，有着更大的道德强调。所以我认为你只是看到这一点以不同的方式表现出来，我们对诚实有不同的道德态度，特别是在这种生命尽头的时刻。我可以想象在一个像美国这样的个人主义国家，人们可能会说，你知道，如果一个人只剩下三个月生命，你绝对应该告诉他们，因为这让他们能够处理好自己的事务。
order. It allows them to say goodbye. It allows them to leave on their own terms. And there's just as much an argument to be made for that as to say, they're going to die anyway in three months time. Why burdened them with this knowledge in addition to whatever else they're going through? Right. I think either argument and either set of values is totally reasonable. I think part of what's interesting is that they're culturally defined. And so it's recognizing the value of prioritizing, the value of prioritizing, the moral imperative that matches the context in the person. I can imagine then that in cross-cultural contexts where people from different cultures are coming into contact with each other, this can create problems because, of course, someone from,
它让他们能够告别。它让他们能够按照自己的方式离开。而且，说“他们反正三个月后就要死了，为什么要用这些知识加上他们正在经历的其他任何事情来增加他们的负担”的论点也同样成立。没错。我认为任何论点和任何价值观体系都是完全合理的。我认为有趣的部分是它们是文化定义的。所以这是认识到优先考虑的价值，优先考虑的价值，即与环境和个人相匹配的道德要求。我可以想象，在不同文化背景的人们相互接触的跨文化环境中，这可能会产生问题，因为当然，来自，
let's say, China might say it is a humane and kind and generous thing to do to lie, and somebody from the United States might say, no, it's the most cruel thing you can do to lie. That must happen all the time. Yeah, I think it's incredibly complicated. actually recently ran a set of studies looking at physicians' predictions of patient preferences in the U.S. and in China. And in the U.S., also looking at their prediction of white patients' preferences versus Chinese-American patient preferences. And it's quite interesting in that in China, the patients do prefer more false hope than in the U.S., and Chinese doctors get that somewhat
比方说，中国的人可能会说撒谎是一件人道、善良和慷慨的事情，而来自美国的人可能会说，不，撒谎是你所能做的最残忍的事情。这种情况一定经常发生。是的，我认为这极其复杂。实际上最近进行了一系列研究，观察医生对美国和中国患者偏好的预测。在美国，也观察了他们对白人患者偏好与华裔美国患者偏好的预测。非常有趣的是，在中国，患者确实比在美国更喜欢虚假的希望，而中国医生对此有些
inaccurate. But in the U.S., the U.S. doctors think that Chinese American patients also prefer false hope similar to the native Chinese patients. And they don't. They look a lot more like white American preferences closer to preferring honesty. And so there's just a lot of room for complicated misunderstandings when we try to accommodate these differences. So far, we've been talking about situations in which the person to whom we might lie is vulnerable or incapacitated. When we come back, we look at another category of lies that most people feel are acceptable, lies that are shaped by the nature of the information itself. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam.
不准确。但在美国，美国医生认为华裔美国患者也像本土中国患者一样更喜欢虚假的希望。但他们并不喜欢。他们看起来更像白人美国人的偏好，更接近于喜欢诚实。所以当我们试图适应这些差异时，有很多空间产生复杂的误解。到目前为止，我们一直在谈论我们可能对其撒谎的人处于脆弱或无能为力状态的情况。回来后，我们将看看大多数人认为可以接受的另一类谎言，即由信息本身的性质所塑造的谎言。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。
This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. Have you had situations in your life where you feel you had to lie, or situations where you had to shade the truth? If you'd be willing to share your story with the Hidden Brain audience, please record a voice memo on your phone and email it to us at Feedback at Hiddenbrain.org. Use the subject line, lies. That email address again is Feedback at Hiddenbrain.org. Psychologist Emma Levine studies truth-telling and deception.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。你的生活中是否有过你觉得必须撒谎的情况，或者你不得不掩盖真相的情况？如果你愿意与《隐藏的大脑》的听众分享你的故事，请在手机上录制一段语音备忘录，并发送电子邮件至 Feedback@hiddenbrain.org。使用主题行“谎言”。那个电子邮件地址再次是 Feedback@hiddenbrain.org。心理学家艾玛·莱文研究说真话和欺骗。
Her research suggests that the clear and simple line we often seek to draw, always tell the truth, is more complicated, in practice. There are harmful truths and there are selfless lies. Emma, you find that many people think it's okay to lie about things that involve subjective judgment. You once came up with a vignette involving a silk scarf worn by a co-worker. Describe that story. Describe that scenario for me. Sure. So imagine you have a co-worker who is wearing a scarf that they love, but you think is quite hideous. should you tell them your opinion about the scarf?
她的研究表明，我们经常试图划定的清晰简单的界限——“永远说真话”——在实践中更为复杂。有有害的真话，也有无私的谎言。艾玛，你发现许多人认为在涉及主观判断的事情上撒谎是可以的。你曾经想出一个涉及同事佩戴的丝巾的短片。描述那个故事。为我描述那个场景。当然。所以想象你有一位同事戴着一条他们很喜欢的围巾，但你认为它非常丑陋。你应该告诉他们你对这条围巾的看法吗？
This is the basic scenario. And if you just set it up like that, then about 40% of participants think you should lie and pretend you like the scarf. So already a substantial amount. But now imagine you know for sure that you're the only one who thinks this and everyone else really likes the scarf.
这是基本场景。如果你就这样设定它，那么大约40%的参与者认为你应该撒谎并假装你喜欢这条围巾。所以已经有相当多的人了。但现在想象你确定你是唯一一个这样想的人，而其他所有人都真的很喜欢这条围巾。
Then should you tell them? Now most people, 71% of people, say, no, now you should definitely lie. And so, right, this is hitting this idea of subjectivity. If everyone thinks your scarf is ugly, or it might be the case that everyone thinks your scarf is ugly, then perhaps someone should tell you because you could change and not offend everyone in your office. But if you know, right, this is just your idiosyncratic preference. It's a totally subjective judgment. Then why do you think, right, it should be shared? And that's what's going on here.
那么你应该告诉他们吗？现在大多数人，71%的人，说，不，现在你绝对应该撒谎。所以，对吧，这触及了主观性的概念。如果每个人都认为你的围巾很丑，或者可能每个人都认为你的围巾很丑，那么也许有人应该告诉你，因为你可以改变，而不冒犯办公室里的每个人。但如果你知道，对吧，这只是你个人的偏好。这完全是一个主观判断。那么你为什么认为，对吧，它应该被分享呢？这就是这里发生的事情。
A similar situation when people agree it's okay to lie is when the information involved is trivial. You ran an experiment where you described a dinner party where people didn't like the food? Yeah. So in that scenario, and I run a lot of scenarios in which people have negative opinions of someone else, in this particular scenario, you are asked to imagine that you go to a dinner party and the soup is salty. So the soup is salty. and what we vary across conditions with our participants is whether the host of this dinner party is a professional chef or, right, just a novice cooking for fun. So if the host is a professional chef, the information about the quality of their soup is not trivial. It's kind of important
当涉及的信息微不足道时，人们同意撒谎是可以的，这也是一种类似的情况。你做了一个实验，描述了一个人们不喜欢食物的晚宴？是的。所以在那个场景中，我做了很多人们对别人有负面意见的场景，在这个特定的场景中，你被要求想象你去参加一个晚宴，汤很咸。所以汤很咸。我们与参与者在不同条件下变化的是，这个晚宴的主人是一位专业厨师，还是，对吧，只是一个为了好玩而做饭的新手。如果主人是一位专业厨师，关于汤质量的信息就不是微不足道的。它有点重要，
because this is what they do for a living. So in that situation, only about 20% of participants, actually only 18 to be exact, think that the right. thing to do is to lie. But if you know that the person is a novice chef, just having fun in their kitchen, now a lot more people think you should lie, 37.8%. And this is because the information about the quality of their soup becomes trivial. It's not important or material for any reason. So it's interesting.
因为这是他们赖以生存的职业。所以在那种情况下，只有大约20%的参与者，实际上只有18%的人，认为正确的做法是撒谎。但如果你知道那个人是一个新手厨师，只是在厨房里玩得开心，现在更多的人认为你应该撒谎，37.8%。这是因为关于汤质量的信息变得微不足道了。它没有任何理由变得重要或实质性。所以这很有趣。
It's the same information in both cases. But in one situation, the information carries weight. It matters to a professional chef to know that something is wrong. with his or her cooking, but the same information to a novice chef, you're just hurting the person's feelings. Exactly. And of course, it carries some information either way, and that's why there's not a huge agreement that you should lie, even for the novice chef, but we're varying the degree to which
在两种情况下信息是一样的。但在一种情况下，信息具有分量。对专业厨师来说，知道他的烹饪出了问题很重要，但同样的信息对新手厨师来说，你只是在伤害那个人的感情。没错。当然，无论哪种方式它都带有一定的信息，这就是为什么即使对于新手厨师，也没有达成巨大的共识认为你应该撒谎，但我们正在改变该信息具有意义和价值的程度。
that information is meaningful and valuable. So sometimes we encounter situations in which another person cannot do anything to control or change what has happened. You came up with one scenario involving the case of an intern who stuttered. What was this example and how did the experiment unfold, Emma? In this experiment, participants are imagining that summer intern gives an end-of-summer presentation, something I had to do in my life as an intern way back when. So they're giving a presentation and they stutter during it, making the presentation a bit
所以有时我们会遇到另一个人无法做任何事情来控制或改变已经发生的事情的情况。你提出了一个涉及口吃实习生的案例的场景。这个例子是什么，实验是如何展开的，艾玛？在这个实验中，参与者想象那个暑期实习生做了一个暑期结束的演讲，这是我很久以前作为实习生时必须做的事情。所以他们正在做演讲，他们在演讲过程中口吃，使得演讲有点
hard to listen to. And you learn that either this stutter was driven by nerves, that this intern was nervous, but they can likely overcome this stutter with more practice, or you learn that this person has a stutter that they cannot control. In this study, that influences the endorsement of deception. So 18.8% of participants say you should lie when the person can improve their ability to speak without a stutter when it was just nerves. But now the majority start thinking it's ethical to lie, 64.4% when the person cannot control their stutter. So the degree to which the information is something you can learn from
难以听懂。你得知这个口吃要么是由紧张引起的，那个实习生很紧张，但他们很可能通过更多的练习克服这个口吃，或者你得知这个人有他们无法控制的口吃。在这项研究中，这影响了对欺骗的认可。当那个人可以通过练习提高说话能力而没有口吃时，只有18.8%的参与者说你应该撒谎，当它只是紧张时。但现在大多数人开始认为撒谎是合乎道德的，64.4%，当那个人无法控制他们的口吃时。所以信息是你可以从中学习的程度，
and that can lead to change seems to be what's driving that difference. What's so interesting is as you're painting these scenarios, I can see my own feelings and opinions change. I mean, if you tell me that the intern cannot control their stutter, of course it changes whether you tell them the truth or not. Right. And I think that's what's so interesting. And one thing I love about this body of research, it's that none of these are actually all that surprising. You tell them to people and everyone's like, yeah, duh, but then why don't we say this out loud? Why don't we teach our children? Why don't we talk about these rules? They're actually quite obvious upon reflection. Another situation involves a manager who has to give some bad news to his employees and has to decide whether to share this bad news with one employee who is about to have a very special weekend.
并且可以导致改变，似乎是推动这种差异的原因。最有趣的是，当你描绘这些场景时，我可以看到我自己的感受和观点在改变。我的意思是，如果你告诉我实习生无法控制他们的口吃，当然这会改变你是否告诉他们真相。没错。我认为这就是最有趣的地方。我喜欢这项研究的一个地方是，这些其实都不太令人惊讶。你告诉人们，每个人都说，是啊，废话，但为什么我们不大声说出来呢？为什么我们不教我们的孩子？为什么我们不谈论这些规则？它们在反思后实际上非常明显。另一种情况涉及一位经理，他必须向员工传达一些坏消息，并且必须决定是否与一位即将度过一个非常特别周末的员工分享这个坏消息。
Paint a picture of this scenario for me. Sure. So this is a scenario about layoffs. The manager knows layoffs are coming. We have to tell the employees. And one of the employees drops by in a Friday afternoon, says, hey, what's going on? I'm about to head out for the weekend. And this is the opportunity for the manager to tell the employees.
为我描绘一下这个场景。当然。所以这是一个关于裁员的场景。经理知道裁员即将到来。我们必须告诉员工。其中一名员工在周五下午顺道过来，说，嘿，怎么了？我正要出去过周末。这是经理告诉员工的机会。
the employee about the layoffs. So in the control condition, that's about all the information that we give participants. And in that case, most people think you should tell the truth. And only about 22, 23 percent of participants think the right thing to do is to lie. Now, in another condition, participants learn that the employee swings by on a Friday before leaving for their wedding, which is on Saturday. Oh, wow. Right. That changes how we think about this. now 52% of participants think that you should lie. So a significant amount more because why would you spoil this person's wedding? You could just tell them right the next week. And this is actually, you know, something that comes up in different religions and different texts. So you really shouldn't
关于裁员。所以在对照组中，这就是我们给参与者的大部分信息。在这种情况下，大多数人认为你应该说真话。只有大约22%、23%的参与者认为正确的做法是撒谎。现在，在另一种情况下，参与者得知员工在周五离开前顺道过来，因为周六是他们的婚礼。哦，哇。没错。这改变了我们对这件事的看法。现在52%的参与者认为你应该撒谎。所以更多的人认为你应该撒谎，因为你为什么要破坏这个人的婚礼呢？你完全可以等到下周再告诉他们。这实际上，你知道，是出现在不同宗教和不同文本中的事情。所以你真的不应该
spoil sacred events. In Judaism, a book called the Talmud, they debate kind of some of these situations. They say you should always tell a bride she's beautiful on her wedding day. Because why would you spoil that special time, no matter what you really think? So when we look at all these varied reasons that people say that lying is okay, there is at least one powerful through line. Is the lie the product of selfish intentions or benevolent intentions? Explain this difference, Emma. So all of these situations, what they're doing is they're mapping this logic of unnecessary harm. You tell the lie and we think that lying is their right thing to do because it's sparing the listener from unnecessary harm. It's protecting
破坏神圣的时刻。在犹太教中，有一本名为《塔木德》的书，里面讨论了这类情况。他们说，在婚礼当天，你应该总是告诉新娘她很美。因为无论你真实想法如何，为什么要破坏那个特殊的时刻呢？所以，当我们审视人们认为撒谎是可以接受的各种理由时，至少有一条强有力的主线。这个谎言是出于自私的意图还是仁慈的意图？艾玛，请解释一下这种区别。所以，所有这些情况，他们实际上是在映射这种“不必要的伤害”的逻辑。你撒了谎，而我们认为撒谎是正确的做法，因为它让听者免受不必要的伤害。它在保护
their feelings when there's nothing they could learn or do with this information. And that's what we think is benevolent. That really promotes or people believe that it promotes the target's best interest to protect them from that unnecessary harm. So in other words, instead of saying don't tell lies is what we really mean to say don't tell selfish lies? We certainly mean don't tell selfish lies. I think it's still quite complicated. In some ways, we really do mean don't tell lies because we're afraid of the risk of allowing people to tell some lies.
他们的感受，而这些信息对他们来说既无法学习也无法利用。这就是我们认为的仁慈。这确实促进了——或者人们相信这促进了——保护目标对象免受不必要的伤害，符合他们的最大利益。换句话说，我们真正想说的不是“不要撒谎”，而是“不要撒自私的谎”吗？我们当然是指不要撒自私的谎。我认为这仍然相当复杂。在某些方面，我们确实是指“不要撒谎”，因为我们担心允许人们撒谎所带来的风险。
So these situations are really robust. We reflect on them. We think in this given situation, when a person can't change or the information is trivial, we should lie. At the same time, we think if we tell people they can lie sometimes, they're also going to get it wrong sometimes and they're going to end up telling selfish lies or telling, well, meaning lies that actually do harm. And we're very, very worried about that error. And so we'd rather live in a world where people tell truths in the wrong circumstances instead of lies in the wrong circumstances. So it's complicated.
所以这些情况确实很稳固。我们反思它们。我们认为在特定情况下，当一个人无法改变现状或者信息无关紧要时，我们应该撒谎。与此同时，我们认为如果我们告诉人们他们有时可以撒谎，他们有时也会搞错，最终会撒自私的谎，或者出于好意却造成了伤害。我们非常非常担心这种错误。因此，我们宁愿生活在一个人们在错误的情况下说真话，而不是在错误的情况下撒谎的世界里。所以这很复杂。
So you found that when people tell these selfless falsehoods, these pro-social lies, that actually these prosocial lies increase trust in the liar? They can. They can increase trust. So in these types of situations, when both parties recognize that telling the lie prevents unnecessary harm, the listener will increase in their belief that the communicator has their best interest in mind. And so that's a certain form of trust. I'm now willing to be emotionally vulnerable to you, to seek you out for support.
所以你发现，当人们说这些无私的谎言，即这些亲社会的谎言时，实际上这些亲社会的谎言增加了对撒谎者的信任？它们可以。它们可以增加信任。因此，在这些类型的情况下，当双方都认识到撒谎可以防止不必要的伤害时，听者会增加对沟通者心怀善意的信念。这就是某种形式的信任。我现在愿意对你敞开心扉，寻求你的支持。
I trust you as someone who is benevolent towards me. And that's really important in some relationships, like going back to the opening example, the relationship I have with my mother. But the double ed short is it still does reduce. integrity-based trust in that despite believing this is someone who I can count on to protect me and care for me and be compassionate, I also recognize that I can't always count on the veracity of their words. And so it increases one type of trust, benevolence-based trust, while still undermining integrity-based trust. You know, in some ways, I think many of us simultaneously
我相信你是一个对我怀有善意的人。这在某些关系中非常重要，比如回到开头的例子，我和我母亲的关系。但双刃剑在于，它确实降低了基于诚信的信任。尽管我相信这是一个我可以依靠来保护我、关心我并富有同情心的人，但我同时也意识到，我不能总是依赖他们言语的真实性。因此，它增加了一种信任，即基于善意的信任，同时却削弱了基于诚信的信任。你知道，在某种程度上，我认为我们许多人同时
want two things that are at odds with one another. We admire people who spare others from needless pain, but we also admire people who say what they think no matter what. You know, I had a friend in college who always said whatever he thought, and he was like a bull in a China shop, and he caused a lot of hurt. But over time, people also came to trust when he told them anything positive because they knew that he was telling the truth. Right. And I think this, again, speaks to the tension and what errors were comfortable with.
想要两样相互矛盾的东西。我们钦佩那些让别人免受不必要痛苦的人，但我们也钦佩那些无论如何都说出自己想法的人。你知道，我在大学里有个朋友，他总是想到什么就说什么，他就像闯进瓷器店的公牛，造成了很多伤害。但随着时间的推移，人们也开始信任他所说的任何积极的话，因为他们知道他在说真话。没错。我认为这再次说明了这种张力，以及我们对哪些错误感到舒适。
So people who are brutal truth tellers have a hard time making friends, but they, right, come to be trusted for their words. And often we'd rather be that person than the person whose words erode in value over time. But these are two very different types of trust nonetheless. Can you want to talk about the idea that benevolent lies sound benevolent, but I'm wondering if there is a thin line sometimes between benevolent lies and selfish lies. Can't we tell lies for selfish reasons and convince ourselves that we have in fact done so for benevolent reasons? Absolutely. And this, again, is another danger in accepting that some lies are good, is that we can convince ourselves that we're in these situations of unnecessary harm when we're really not. So going back to the idea of fragility. In some cases, both parties, communicators and listeners will recognize that the listener is temporarily fragile. They're going through something. Therefore, temporary deception is appropriate. And then telling them the truth at a later time is what a communicator should do.
所以，那些直言不讳的人很难交到朋友，但他们确实因为自己的言语而受到信任。通常我们宁愿成为那样的人，也不愿成为言语价值随时间流逝而贬值的人。但无论如何，这两种信任是非常不同的。你能谈谈这个观点吗：仁慈的谎言听起来很仁慈，但我怀疑仁慈的谎言和自私的谎言之间有时只有一线之隔。我们难道不能为了自私的理由撒谎，却说服自己实际上是出于仁慈的理由吗？绝对可以。这也是接受“有些谎言是好的”这一观点带来的另一个危险，那就是当我们实际上并非处于不必要的伤害情境中时，我们却能说服自己处于这种情境中。回到脆弱性的概念。在某些情况下，双方——沟通者和听者——都会认识到听者暂时是脆弱的。他们正在经历某些事情。因此，暂时的欺骗是适当的。而在稍后的时间告诉他们真相，才是沟通者应该做的。
But once we know that it's easy to see others as fragile, right, I could believe that women in the workplace are fragile. I shouldn't tell them negative feedback. And that might be really to avoid conflict. So that's selfish. It might be based on some stereotype. So it's inaccurate, despite not necessarily being selfish. And it just opens us up to all. of these mistakes, selfish and otherwise. I mean, I'm thinking about the cheating spouse who is not telling her partner that she had the affair, and she says, okay, the partner is 24 hours away from dying, and so I don't want to burden him with this information. But what if your partner is now a week away from dying?
但一旦我们知道这一点，就很容易把别人看作是脆弱的，对吧？我可以认为职场中的女性是脆弱的。我不应该告诉她们负面反馈。这可能确实是为了避免冲突。所以那是自私的。它可能基于某种刻板印象。所以它是不准确的，尽管不一定非得是自私的。这只会让我们陷入所有这些错误中，无论是自私的还是其他的。我的意思是，我想到那个出轨的配偶，她没有告诉伴侣她有外遇，她说，好吧，伴侣离死亡还有24小时，所以我不想用这个信息去负担他。但如果你的伴侣离死亡还有一周呢？
What if your partner is a month away from dying? What if your partner is a year away from dying? At what point is the line between fragility and non-fragility? Right. It's almost impossible to know without asking someone their preferences directly and having their insight into what they want. Otherwise, we're just making this subjective judgment about where the line is. The line exists, but whether we can predict it, a priority is unclear. What do you make of the people who are basically sticking to the honesty is the best policy?
如果你的伴侣离死亡还有一个月呢？如果你的伴侣离死亡还有一年呢？在什么点上，脆弱和非脆弱的界限在哪里？没错。如果不直接询问某人的偏好并了解他们想要什么，几乎是不可能知道的。否则，我们只是在对界限在哪里做出主观判断。界限确实存在，但我们是否能先验地预测它是不清楚的。你如何看待那些基本上坚持“诚实是上策”的人？
So in the many examples that you've given me, it's true. and surprising that significant numbers of people endorse deception at some level, and depending on how you tweak the scenarios, more people endorse deception. But it's also the case clearly in your studies that even in situations where someone is very vulnerable or about to have a wedding or dealing with an important test, there are some people who say, always tell the truth. Your mandate is in fact to follow, thou shalt not lie. Yeah, I think there are individual differences on this. So far we've tapped into the cross-cultural difference, U.S. versus China, but there's also individual differences.
在你给我的许多例子中，确实令人惊讶的是，相当多的人在某种程度上支持欺骗，而且根据你调整场景的方式，更多的人支持欺骗。但显然在你的研究中，即使在某人非常脆弱、即将举行婚礼或面临重要考试的情况下，也有一些人说，永远说真话。你的准则是“不可撒谎”。是的，我认为在这方面存在个体差异。到目前为止，我们已经触及了跨文化差异，即美国与中国，但个体之间也存在差异。
Some people want to know the truth at all times and tell the truth at all times, and some people are more comfortable with these tradeoffs or actually believe that comfort and social harmony sometimes reigns supreme. What you just said makes me think is the distinction between these two groups of people, how much they actually are embedded in their community. and how much they're actually connected to other people. Because I think a very individualistic point of view would say, I always want to be told the truth and I always want to be telling other people the truth. But the more community-minded you are, the more you're embedded in social systems, the more you value those social systems, the more you try and take into account social harmony and how other people are feeling and not just, am I telling the truth or am I being lied to?
有些人希望在任何时候都知道真相并说真话，而有些人则更适应这些权衡，或者实际上认为舒适和社会和谐有时至高无上。你刚才说的话让我想到，这两类人之间的区别在于他们实际上在多大程度上融入了社区，以及他们与他人的联系有多紧密。因为我认为一种非常个人主义的观点会说，我总是希望被告知真相，我也总是希望对别人说真话。但你越有社区意识，你越融入社会系统，你越重视这些社会系统，你就越会尝试考虑社会和谐以及他人的感受，而不仅仅是“我在说真话吗”或者“我被骗了吗”。
I think that's partly right. It's an intuition I certainly had before heading into some cross-cultural research on this topic, which actually proved a bit more complicated than the story you've laid out. So it's easy to make a prediction that in China where there's more collectivism versus the U.S., that they'll value social harmony and be more accepting of deception than in the U.S. And now we see that in the medical context, but that seems to be a function of the belief and importance of hope and things we think about at the end of life and the role of luck, right? So knowing that you have cancer saying out loud can create bad luck. But this actually doesn't carry over into a lot of other situations. So we ran studies looking at beliefs about and preferences for just critical feedback in the U.S. and China. And actually, we see a greater preference for critical feedback in China than in the U.S. And that's for a different reason also related to communities, which is people feel more responsible for each other and their development and their adherence to norms. Right. So if I think we're all part of a community that values working hard, I'm going to tell you when I think you're not working hard.
我认为这部分是对的。在进行关于这个主题的跨文化研究之前，我确实有这种直觉，但研究结果证明比你所描述的故事要复杂得多。所以，很容易做出预测，在中国，集体主义比美国更强，所以他们会重视社会和谐，比美国人更能接受欺骗。现在我们在医疗背景下看到了这一点，但这似乎是对希望的重要性、我们对生命终点时的思考以及运气的角色的信念的一种功能，对吧？所以知道你患有癌症并大声说出来可能会带来厄运。但这实际上并没有延伸到许多其他情况中。所以我们进行了研究，观察美国和中国对批评性反馈的信念和偏好。实际上，我们看到中国对批评性反馈的偏好高于美国。这也是出于另一个与社区有关的原因，即人们感到对彼此以及彼此的发展和对规范的遵守负有更多责任。没错。所以如果我认为我们都是一个重视努力工作的社区的一部分，当我认为你没有努力工作时，我会告诉你的。
that's part of being a good community member is valuing your growth. Whereas in the U.S., it's like you do you, you know, you don't want to work hard, but I do. I'm not responsible for your individual choices. And so you see that playing out quite differently. You had an experience of being lied to during the COVID pandemic. Describe for me what happened, Emma. So I was pregnant during the beginning of the pandemic. So I was very, very focused on knowing all of the risk.
那是成为一名优秀社区成员的一部分，即重视你的成长。而在美国，就像是“你做你自己的事”，你知道，你不想努力工作，但我想。我不对你的个人选择负责。所以你会看到这种情况表现得非常不同。你在新冠疫情期间有过被欺骗的经历。请描述一下发生了什么，艾玛。我在疫情初期怀孕了。所以我非常非常专注于了解所有的风险，
and what was going on and protecting me and my now born a child. So one thing that happened was my parents were supposed to come to town to help me prepare and set up as I was awaiting the birth of my daughter. And they were under strict instruction that they were not to socialize. They should not socialize with anyone. They should not see anyone. There was no way I was going to let even single germ into my household in the days before my daughter was born. And we had a Zoom call shortly before they were supposed to come. And they're
以及正在发生的事情，并保护我和我当时尚未出生的孩子。所以发生的一件事是，我的父母本应来到城里帮助我准备和布置，因为我正在等待女儿的出生。他们受到严格的指示，不得进行社交活动。他们不应该与任何人社交。他们不应该见任何人。在我女儿出生前的日子里，我绝不可能让哪怕一个细菌进入我的家庭。在他们本应到来之前不久，我们进行了一次Zoom通话。他们
talking to my aunt kind of casually, but I'm there. And they're mentioning that they had their friends over for pizza. And I had been assured that there was no socializing. And it turns out, well, there had been socializing. There was a bit of a deception. And, you know, I talked to my mother about this. And she said, I didn't, I didn't want to burden you. I didn't want to worry you. We were outside. We didn't even come in contact with each other. We were on the deck. We stayed socially distanced. I'm confident there's absolutely no risk to you. So I just didn't think it was necessary to know. So this is not actually unlike what she did during your wedding. Was your reaction the same? No, it was different. And this again points to
正在和我的阿姨随意交谈，但我也在场。他们提到他们请朋友过来吃披萨。我之前被保证过没有社交活动。结果发现，好吧，确实有社交活动。有一点欺骗。而且，你知道，我和我母亲谈过这件事。她说，我没有，我不想给你增加负担。我不想让你担心。我们在外面。我们甚至没有互相接触。我们在露台上。我们保持了社交距离。我相信你绝对没有风险。所以我只是觉得没必要让你知道。所以这实际上和你婚礼期间她所做的事情没什么不同。你的反应一样吗？不，不一样。这再次指出了
some of the risks of trying to get this trade-off right. So here, I was very upset. I actually didn't let them come. I made them wait a whole week and get tested. I was, yes, very concerned about all of this. But I was upset. And it's not because her motivations were different. I think the motivations were the same.
试图正确处理这种权衡的一些风险。在这里，我非常不安。我实际上没有让他们来。我让他们等了整整一周并接受了检测。是的，我确实非常担心所有这些。但我很不安。这并不是因为她的动机不同。我认为动机是一样的。
They were benevolent. She didn't want to stress me out in a situation that she didn't think provided, necessary information, right, along the logic that I've outlined before. But in this situation, I did feel the information was necessary. We had different beliefs. And so the lie felt very paternalistic and unfair, not pro-social as it had before. I'm wondering if you've had a conversation with your mom, Emma, laying out when and how she's allowed to tell you benevolent lies and when she's not.
他们是仁慈的。她不想在一种她认为没有提供必要信息的情况下让我感到压力，对吧？遵循我之前概述的逻辑。但在这种情况下，我确实觉得这些信息是必要的。我们有不同的信念。所以这个谎言感觉非常家长式且不公平，而不是像之前那样是亲社会的。我想知道你是否和你的妈妈谈过，艾玛，明确规定她什么时候可以对你撒仁慈的谎，什么时候不可以。
I probably should. I haven't done it. Which is, now that you ask a bit strange, because I do give the advice to other people and in my papers, that one way to avoid this risk is to have conversations about this, right? To have explicit kind of social contracts. What type of feedback do you like in what situations? Doctors can do this with patients? How much do you want to know everything and every risk or do you want to just focus on each next step in the plan moving forward? So there are ways to have these conversations so that you can be sure you're airing on the side of benevolence when it's really benevolent, when it aligns with the listener's interests. We haven't had that conversation, and perhaps we should. In our companion story to this episode, exclusively on Hidden Brain Plus, we explore ways to bridge the gap between the many lies we condone in practice and the lying we claim to abhor.
我可能应该谈谈。我还没做过。这，现在你问起来有点奇怪，因为我确实给别人建议，在我的论文中也提到，避免这种风险的一种方法是进行这些对话，对吧？建立明确的社会契约。你喜欢在什么情况下得到什么样的反馈？医生可以和病人这样做吗？你想知道每一件事和每一个风险，还是只想专注于前进计划中的每一步？所以有办法进行这些对话，这样你就可以确保在真正仁慈、符合听者利益时，你是在倾向于仁慈。我们还没有进行过那样的对话，也许我们应该谈谈。在我们这一集的配套故事中，仅在Hidden Brain Plus上，我们探讨了弥合我们在实践中宽恕的许多谎言与我们声称厌恶的撒谎行为之间差距的方法。
Instead of exalting the truth while telling lies, what would happen if we told the truth about our lying ways? If you're a subscriber to Hidden Brain Plus, that episode is available in your podcast feed right now. It's titled, Telling the Truth about Lies. If you're not yet a subscriber, please visit support.hiddenbrain.org
与其在撒谎的同时颂扬真相，如果我们对我们的撒谎方式说真话会怎样？如果你是Hidden Brain Plus的订阅者，那一集现在就在你的播客订阅源中。标题是《说出关于谎言的真相》。如果你还不是订阅者，请访问support.hiddenbrain.org
or apple.com slash hiddenbrain. Again, that's support. hiddenbrain.org. If you're using an Apple device, go to apple.co slash hidden brain. Emma Levine is a psychologist at the University of Chicago's Booth School of Business.
或apple.com/hiddenbrain。再说一遍，是support.hiddenbrain.org。如果你使用的是苹果设备，请访问apple.co/hiddenbrain。艾玛·莱文是芝加哥大学布斯商学院的心理学家。
Emma, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thanks for having me. It's been a blast. Have you had situations in your life where you feel you had to tell a benevolent lie but later came to regret it? If you have a personal story you'd be willing to share with the Hidden Brain audience
艾玛，非常感谢你今天参加Hidden Brain。谢谢你的邀请。这太棒了。在你的生活中，有没有过你觉得不得不撒一个仁慈的谎，但后来感到后悔的情况？如果你有一个愿意与Hidden Brain听众分享的个人故事，
or a question or comment about this episode, please find a very quiet room and record a voice memo on your phone. Two or three minutes is plenty. Email the file to us at Feedback at Hiddenbrain.org. Use the subject line, lies. Again, that email address is feedback at hiddenbrain.org. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media.
或者关于这一集的问题或评论，请找一个非常安静的房间，在你的手机上录制一段语音备忘录。两三分钟就足够了。将文件通过电子邮件发送给我们，地址是Feedback@Hiddenbrain.org。使用主题行“lies”。再说一遍，电子邮件地址是feedback@hiddenbrain.org。Hidden Brain由Hidden Brain Media制作。
Our audio production team includes Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Querell, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, Andrew Chadwick, and Nick Woodbury. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. Thank you to Loom by Atlassian for sponsoring the Hidden Brain Perceptions Tour. While on tour, audience members shared the best piece of advice they've ever received. Here's a piece of advice that a listener named Suzanne shared at our tour stop in Baltimore. I'm Suzanne from D.C. and my best advice, came from my Pyongyang-born mother who loved to speak in Confucian proverbs. She often said to us,
我们的音频制作团队包括安妮·墨菲-保罗、克里斯汀·王、劳拉·奎雷尔、瑞安·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯、安德鲁·查德威克和尼克·伍德伯里。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是Hidden Brain的执行编辑。感谢Atlassian的Loom赞助Hidden Brain感知之旅。在巡演期间，观众分享了他们收到的最好的建议。这是一位名叫苏珊的听众在我们巴尔的摩巡演站分享的建议。我是来自华盛顿特区的苏珊，我最好的建议来自我出生于平壤的母亲，她喜欢用儒家谚语说话。她经常对我们说，
never spit in the well because you never know when you have to drink the water. And she told this so many times as children, and I was like, what is she talking about? But I really understood it as an adult, and I realized it really meant how important to maintain relationships with people. So, thank you. Thank you. Wonderful. Thank you. Thanks to Suzanne for sharing this bit of advice, and thanks again to Loom for sponsoring the Perceptions Tour. Loom is AI-first-powered video communication that moves teams forward, whether you're sharing feedback, obtaining approvals, or setting context.
永远不要往井里吐痰，因为你永远不知道什么时候必须喝那里的水。她小时候无数次这样说，我当时想，她在说什么？但作为成年人，我真正理解了它，我意识到它真正意味着维护人际关系是多么重要。所以，谢谢。谢谢。太棒了。谢谢。感谢苏珊分享这个建议，再次感谢Loom赞助感知之旅。Loom是人工智能优先的视频通信工具，可以推动团队前进，无论你是分享反馈、获得批准还是设定背景。
Reduce unnecessary meetings and make the ones that matter more effective. Unstuck your teams today at loom.com. That's L-O-O-O-M dot com. It's a team changer. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
减少不必要的会议，让重要的会议更有效。今天就在loom.com上让你的团队摆脱困境。那是L-O-O-O-M点com。这是一个团队改变者。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。很快再见。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。